I had to look it up I was like how did
this movie get that MCU money without
being a part of the MCU without being a
part of a Cinematic Universe
it didn't
[Music]
so the creators directed by Gareth
Edwards who directed Rogue one a Star
Wars story also directed that Godzilla
movie that came out 2014 I believe so
the plot of the Creator is AI had been
established we used robots for you know
labor and such I feel like you know
where this is going La gets nuked by Ai
and now America is at war with AI a new
Asia the Territory called New Asia is
not they Embrace AI don't know much
about how the rest of the world deals
with AI but those two countries deal
with it with war not war the AI has this
new end game weapon so John David
Washington and a bunch of soldiers go in
to find this weapon neutralize the
weapon the weapon turns out to be this
little kid little AI robot kid but
little kid nonetheless after that it's
pretty much the last of us with AI I
guess I mean there's actually a few
different movies you see in here
inspiration from here and there however
I constantly operate on the belief that
any movie out there can be described by
saying this movie and that movie went
Splat some movies blatant rip off other
films some have homage and some use
familiar plot points but execute it in a
way that feels new I feel like that's
what this movie does I mean if I'm gonna
call it last of us with AI I mean Logan
was the last of us also so there's that
John David Washington I would say leads
the film there's a difference between
leads the film and steals to show I'll
get to her in a second John David
Washington's late in the film in the
men's solid solid Soldier type would
have been fine and he's fine in that
role but you need someone who's also
progressively more human as he starts
questioning Humanity itself and I
thought the emotional scenes were where
he shine best this movie has a great
support cast too Gemma Chan Ken Watanabe
Allison Janny as the villain gotta say
she is incredible to play in a complete
and total deck she's kind of the
illustration of people in this world and
how they see the war they're fighting
you know it's said often in this film
like no no we're not killing the robots
we're just turning them off we're
flipping a switch I just found it
interesting that most villains when they
kill people they know they're killing p
people they they know they're being a
dick in that moment they may say the
ends justify the means but to her
particular character she's just turning
off the computer it doesn't mean
anything to her you can make an argument
she doesn't even have that ends justify
the means kind of mentality she's just
like why would I have that I'm just
turning off Machinery turn off your
phone you're a dick too right doesn't
really add up why am I a Dick these are
some of the themes that are in this film
doesn't always Hammer home all of its
themes but the themes are here and I can
appreciate that but the little AI girl
in this film named alfies played by an
actress named Madeleine univoyles and I
was like what else has she been in I got
it
nothing
this is her movie This is the first time
she's ever been on screen what can I say
sometimes you have what is called a gift
and she apparently has that you know how
little kid acting can be in movies
sometimes I thought she was great she's
the heart of the film now there is
something about the vibe of this film
maybe it's because it's an original
story
but it kind of there was something James
Cameron about it I mean that as a
compliment because I love James Cameron
I think he's incredible for nothing else
I can go into any one of his movies I
know that I'm going to be thoroughly
entertained but there was something
about this movie that reminded me of mid
to late 80s James Cameron like if 80s
James Cameron was given the budget and
Technology of 2023 what would that film
look like it would probably look
something like this and that comes down
to World building I always thought
Cameron was great at World building so
is Gareth Edwards it's a world that
feels lived in also plays to its
strengths it could have fallen into the
cliches of the stories we've seen a
hundred times over as it sounded like it
was going to when I was describing this
movie at the beginning of this video but
it never does it's a personal story
about these two people traversing this
world that's at War a world that is
asking questions about what is
intelligence what is artificial
intelligence how is that different than
us again it doesn't always hit that
point home the Dig kind of frustrate me
a bit but this movie was undeniably at
its most interesting when it was
dabbling into those themes also going to
illustrate again the budget of this film
I looked it up it's a round quick Google
search tells me 80 million dollars I
have seen movies with astronomically
larger budgets be dwarfed by the visuals
in this film the best CGI is a CGI you
don't notice there are a lot of films
out there that use CGI but you know
largely for backdrop purposes you don't
tend to notice that when you can have me
watching a futuristic film with war
segments dealing with tech that we don't
even have
and I still it doesn't look like CGI to
me just it feels like I'm in the future
that's a win I will say there were a
couple of moments of dialogue in here
where you can read the lips and the lips
did not say what the person said that
was an F-bomb that I did not hear the
film is PG-13 I feel like there might be
a rated R cut a director's cut of the
film that might make it to home release
I don't know as well as a three hour cut
at least there were some themes that
were cut short some scenes that I felt
like it was sped through in Parts it's
one of those rare movies where I could
have gone for the movie being a little
longer
I'm just saying editing wise it does
have a bit of that jumping back and
forth that Christopher Nolan loves now
everyone's like I I guess we'll all do
that look in the end the Creator it was
solid it was memorable the acting was
great the world feels full it feels
alive the action sequences they're
exciting they have tension but in the
end it's an emotional film did it stick
the landing of that absolutely maybe
you're a fan of sci-fi or maybe you just
want to see a gold standard of how to
use an 80 million dollar budget and film
in any case the Creator's worth watching
and worth buying on Blu-ray all right so
the Creator have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]